now where this really gains some teeth
okay is um when we say all this is
indefinite integrals all its indefinite
integrals okay but if you have a
definite integral and you have some
boundaries
this becomes both more powerful but you
have to be a little more careful with it
because so far I keep on saying we've
got two things to change here right
you've got a function and then you've
got your variable function variable
function variable you go change but
they've got a match with each other
right
and that's what we're done you can see
by this point everything in the question
has been translated to be use so what I
do is I'm gonna take the same question
but I'm gonna give it some boundary
values and I'm going to turn it into a
definite integral
okay
sometimes yep in this case it will they
wouldn't because when you have a look at
this die this is going to be this would
be a semicircle of some kind actually it
would be an ellipse or a semi ellipse
sorry and so then you want to be
thinking the reciprocal valued early
exists in a certain domain by alright so
save me to grow but I'm gonna give it
some boundaries okay these are the
boundaries that I picked before yep
okay now here's what I'm going to do
because I'm taking a divided of this
question because we know exactly what
it's going to turn into so we don't need
to do any extra mental work you've
already gotten written down what this is
going to turn to in terms of use okay in
terms of the function and the variable
you're integrating with respect to
however now that we have boundaries we
should write one more life here which is
it's optional it's kind of it's going to
look a little bit weird but I think it's
really really helpful when I write it
down you'll see why okay
see these variables yeah sorry these
boundaries right they are X values yes
so that when you put this into the
derivative function you're substituting
these in for whatever X is okay so it's
something kind of implied here that X is
equal to root 2 on 3 and X is equal to 1
yes okay now we've seen what happens
you've got to be careful that what those
variables are what the boundaries are
you say they're over because if you're
integrating in a different direction
like say if you're integrating with
respect to Y you want Y boundaries not X
boundaries so we saw that with volumes
right if you're going around this axis
instead of various actors the safety is
happening here so now if you got another
color this would be really helpful now
you can see there's not two things
function variables function variables
that you need to change there are three
right let's highlight all of them right
now here here and here the three things
that you need to change are what we saw
before the function that's the obvious
bin
there's the variable you are integrating
with respect to
we already saw how easy that was to work
with but the last bit the bit that's so
easy to miss is these boundary values
over here these boundaries have to come
along for the ride okay now the reason
why we often miss them is because when
you first write down an integral because
petitions are so amazing we're like yeah
ok like 99.99999% of your integrals are
always theirs back to X that's why we
don't bother saying x equals x equals
cuz you're just gonna
have a whole bunch of redundant notation
well we're about to change everything so
it's the lot in terms of X right so
therefore I like to write this line this
line here like I said it's optional but
it reminds me hey there's another thing
you need to change it's a very very
common error to go through this whole
process and forget to change the
batteries and then you get a hold it for
a moment or you get it up which doesn't
exist depending on the function okay so
we already used this thing over here on
the right hand side I'm not gonna make
you rewrite it these are the tools we
use to change the [ __ ] should change the
variables how am I going to change the
boundaries
I kicked it so these are my X values
right if I'm going to change everything
Terms of Use
I just want to know what's u equal to
those X values okay so I'm going to say
to get off on the right honestly where
I've written this as well because it's
it's all of my side working to do the
substitution I'm gonna say when u equals
and then I'm going to do an evaluation
so sorry when X when x equals I'm gonna
check each of the batteries internal do
that small one a little bit a big one
when x equals root two on three U is
going to equal three are two types that
right yeah so you can see here my feed
to get a care tool I'm gonna be there
for the roof - odd - which is that's one
on rutube you can see where to tell you
actually comes from right so I'm going
to need to substitute into the inverse
trig function that's the lower boundary
on the upper boundary as well which is I
chose 1 over 3
so what am i doing this time
yeah good because 3 to 5 by root 3 is
with dreams on to begin nice can be
value depth now I'm ready I'm gonna do
the same substitution that I did before
like you already see where this is gonna
go with one additional thing I've got
new boundaries as well have here to
indicate have got new boundaries instead
of finding the x equals x equals these
are you boundaries right no ok so you
can see for me this is a mental tag
captions this end is n DS so writing
this kind of helps me so I'm going from
one on root 2 root 3 on shoe
there's the boundaries that have been
changed I'll change the rest of it as
well
cancel cancel everything one two three
all the terms of you know okay so I'm
going to go ahead I already know what
the integral is going to be it's going
to be
I'm just not choosing not to rewrite it
because you have just written it and
it's exactly the same now to us saying
if I wanted to you know at this point
here we're like yeah we introduced you
you must apply the original practice
that's why we came back to this okay if
you really wanted to you could change
this back have that in there and then
subbing your old X boundaries you're
going to get exactly the same result but
the whole point of it is that X you
they're all dummy variables right
they're all known variables it's just
standing in for some numbers so we might
as well change everything at once and
then you can just keep going through and
not return back to your X's then the X's
are never going to be there in the first
place if it's a definition let's go
ahead and evaluate
so here I'm thinking about what is the
angle in what domain what domain is sine
inverse interested so I should say one
range from negative PI to 2 pi on to so
in that range
what angle when I take the side of it
will give me root 3 on 2 the answer is
60 degrees or PI on three
however I've in calculus land right now
yeah so I can't use degrees all of our
true characters results depended on
radians okay so therefore so is the
majority but I've got no space
I'm very value at the first one that's
going to be PI on three must must must
be in radians and then here what's the Y
angle that's gonna give me one a root 2
and that's 45 degrees or PI over 4
radians right so I'm going to go take
away or pretty sure that's gonna be PI
on 12 right so that's PI on 36 ok the
original question had nothing to do with
it area so yeah
therefore I'm not gonna tell you it's
squid or anything like that I'm just
evaluating
we substituted it to you that was
correct
that's exactly right so the question was
like at the moment I actually don't know
what these numbers are but Richard 3 is
okay we're just like 1.4 ish so this is
going to be like point four ish or so
and this is one divided by one point
seven which is going to be a bit bigger
than 1/2 because 1 over 2 what I've
wanted so this is bigger than a heart
this is smaller than half so I'm going
in the normal direction from a small
number to a big number if you do it in
reverse what effect does that have when
you're integrating from a bigger number
to a smaller number yeah you're into
aiding in reverse right so therefore
it's the same as I could use the
property of switching them around it's
like you might assign on the front but
whichever I'm doing I have to preserve
which boundaries which if they're asking
you to go from B to a and this is going
to go from my new me to my new a or
whatever those are gonna be okay all
right
does that make sense any questions
so it's like right now for the next
boundaries
it's like smaller bigger but then okay
that's a great question so I'm gonna
refer back to there's like a lower
boundary for X and another value for X
and they retain that whatever order
they're in they stay the order they're
in and one of the interesting that
happens is and it's doesn't take too
much imagination to see how you do this
a small number here can turn into a big
number over here and and vice versa
so what you might end up getting I mean
here your line it is a minus sign right
and negative sign would do it would turn
this value into a bigger one that so
then I'm going to integrate from big to
small okay
but the boundaries need to stay in their
places and that's what this so helpfully
demonstrates it's like this one turns
into this one and this one turns into
this one if that ends up making these
like bigger to smaller then this one is
also going to change right does that
make sense
so let's just do a really really trivial
example if I if I went from saying okay
integral from 1 to 2 of X DX
okay this is a pretty trivial ok that's
a trapezium isn't it do you see where X
is why don't you yeah now obviously I
don't need to use substitution for this
ok by just suppose I said let's get some
special let's just suppose I said let u
equal minus X I can do any substitution
of like if I what if it's convenient to
me okay so in this case I'm gonna say do
you on DX is okay and X is actually
going to be equal to negative u does
that make sense that's something you're
all this substance you do all right so
that's that and then when I say ok one
of my boundary is going to be well when
X is equal to 1 U is going to be equal
to negative 1 and when X is equal
- right so what is this integral going
to become it's gonna get for the
negative Club - negative - right
what else is gonna what else is going to
change this is going to be negative you
good tip-out yeah ever done anything
wrong cancel cancel cancel cancel
alright this looks a bit weird right
okay let's just go to the bitter end
here okay this is going to become so you
see even the case where oh wait that is
verse not what I what did I need to put
a minus sign there to fix it no no no
whatever made the signs turn around so
that instead of going from small to big
I'm now going from free to small that's
going to be that's going to come out in
the wash over here it has to that's the
reason why I changed the boundaries
around so of course in this case 4 on 2
minus 1/2 so which is the same thing
you'd expected ok so yeah that's okay
don't worry about trying to compensate
for yourself
just keep the boundaries the same in the
same order that they were whatever they
were that's a good question